[Music]
do less and attract more today i
actually had this experience i'd said no
to something that i really wanted to do
old gabby would have 100 000 freaking
percent pushed herself
made that the whole thing happened
reorganized her entire schedule just
pushed push pushed put herself into some
maybe some uncomfortable sort of chaotic
time constraints just to get that thing
done to maximize
and yeah i probably would have gotten
something out of it and it would have
been valuable but at my own expense it
would have been potentially exhausting
it would have taken me out and that
doing might have kept me
from some really important allowance we
have this sense often that the more we
do the more we'll succeed
it could not be more the opposite for me
in this instance now i'm realizing 22
years behind me 16 years as a spiritual
teacher
22 years as a spiritual entrepreneur
i can see and look back and say
i wish i'd done some a little less and
to be clear i wouldn't change anything
because i do genuinely believe that the
universe has a plan for us and even the
things that we wish we'd known
if we had known them something different
would have happened but moving forward
i'm going to really apply
do less and attract more
because the more we push and hustle and
try to be everywhere and be everything
and say yes to everything the less
energy we have for creativity the less
space we have for cultivating the
creative mindset that we need to allow
inspired ideas to move through us
the less space that we have to let the
universe give us direction and show us
where to go and what to do hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that's holding you back a lack
of belief in yourself you watch these
videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and get some incredible motivation
from the one and only gabby bernstein
enjoy
we live in a world that reinforces a
scarcity mentality and that mentality
keeps us an energy of lack it keeps us
from attracting the career path that we
want the abundance that we want and
allowing us to really live our purpose
there are six common blocks to abundance
and we all experience them in different
ways
the first block is a lack mentality and
when we have a belief system around lack
we create more lack in our life we all
have stories from our childhood how our
parents experienced abundance or how
they didn't and those stories start to
create a inner dialogue that gets us
into a vibration of feeling like we
don't have enough
and if we feel like we don't have enough
we do a lot of work to try to prove to
the world that we are enough
the second block is the belief system
that there's not enough to go around
we often overwork to try to get it all
we're constantly trying to get get get
because we don't believe that there is
enough it makes us feel like we have to
work so hard to get what we want and
that effort and that anxiety is really
really blocking the natural order which
is the flow abundance
the third block is the block of
comparison
we
literally just turn on our social media
and we're immediately into compare
compare compare
and comparing blocks are attracting
power because it focuses us on what we
don't have rather than feeling good and
feeling faith
the fourth block is the need to win in
the place of having fun because when
we're so focused on winning we lose
track of what it feels like to enjoy the
process and that winning can really get
in our way of allowing
the fifth block is the fear of rejection
when we fear rejection we don't take
action and in effect we create more lack
in our life because we're not actually
trying we're not actually putting out
our desires we're not actually taking
that leap towards what we want
but it's important to understand that
rejection can be protection
when we have some form of rejection show
up in our life it's the universe guiding
us to something better
and the final block is the fear of
judgment
you may be so terrified of being judged
that you don't take that action you
don't show up for your dreams you don't
even contemplate a world where you could
do the thing that you've been dreaming
of you're so afraid of judgment because
you think that other people won't
support you but what's really important
to recognize is that if you're afraid of
what other people think and how they
won't support you it's typically a sign
that you are not supporting yourself now
that you know the six blocks to
abundance i want to give you my methods
for clearing those blocks so that you
can allow abundance to flow to you it's
called the universal abundance method
the first step of the universal
abundance method is to protect your
desires so you can stay in alignment
so if you have a really important desire
something that you care about something
that you want to manifest into your life
it's extremely valuable not to talk
about it with anyone who might resist it
step two is to focus on giving rather
than getting
the more we are in that service
mentality
the more positively the universe
responds to us this puts you into an
abundance mentality quickly because the
more you give the more you will receive
and step three is to want more for
others
it is an opportunity for us to see that
we all can succeed we all can have
abundance in our life and the second you
start to intend for others to have more
of what you want for yourself you start
to feel good you start to feel like
you're contributing you start to feel
like you're connecting and you're no
longer comparing or jealous and you're
no longer separating yourself from
others redirect your focus from what can
i get to how do i feel
and really allow that feeling of
abundance to propel you forward and
create momentum and allow the universe
to bring to you all that you desire one
of the biggest blocks to being a super
attractor
is the comparison and the belief that
there's not enough to go around and i
actually wrote a whole chapter in the
book called there's more than enough to
go around
and it's for that person that's like the
pusher that i identified in the book the
person that's like if i don't do it it
won't happen
and everybody around me is better than
me or i'm not or i'm better than
everybody else and that separation and
that judgment that self-attack and all
the ways that we feel unworthy and so
when we start to identify the ways that
we're pushing and controlling we can
begin to unpack that and i guide the
reader in the book to unpack that
behavior and to recognize how much it's
blocking someone from from allowing and
letting what they desire to come into
their life because the real secret
is to feel good the secret is to
love where you are in the moment and not
compare yourself to where you think you
should be because once you start just
being psyched about what is
more of what you desire comes to you and
i can stand behind that wholeheartedly i
get a call from my one of my team
members and she's like uh don't go on
facebook i was like what she's like
there's a whole
person's facebook page and they're
railing on you and they're going off
about you
and
maybe like 30 people had chimed in being
like oh you hate gabby brizzy thank god
somebody's talking about it
she's like you know going after me yeah
and
well 30 people is a small number in the
grand scheme of the universe this feels
really overwhelming and and even one
person hating you on the internet can
can shake you to your core
so i
lo i just i do what anyone would do in
that moment and i start to go down that
hole of of shame and upset and what did
i do wrong and how could i have
triggered these people in this way and
what you know what is my part and just
getting so hooked into it even though
you know a lot of what was being said
was being said without any information
right uh you know but regardless i
didn't even need to dig into it to feel
the feelings of discomfort and i was
getting really really hung up about it
really hung up about it and took you
know probably it was about a full day of
just like
being down and bummed out and i remember
i was watching television with my
husband at night i was staring at my
phone just being like did more people
weigh in like what's happening and he
looks at me he's like what is going on
what you can't even be present with me
in this room why are you so stuck in
this i was like it feels so horrible to
be
you know pounded on on the internet and
i'm so upset about it and he said listen
you've got it all wrong girl this is how
my husband became my guru and he said
you are focusing all your energy on
these 30 people who are hating you
but you have thousands of people on your
dm on instagram that are trying to send
you love that are asking you questions
that want your support and you don't
even know how to find your dms
you and me were in the same boat for a
long time yeah yeah and he's like you
don't even know how to find it he's like
let me show you how to find your dm and
focus on the people that need you not on
these people that are hating on you so
i spend the next four days just dm'ing i
dm'ing dm like i went on my instagram i
was like yo who wants a dm
and so i'm just like in it and in it and
just feeling so like within 48 hours i
was just like so transformed by just
being in the service of others and
connecting to the people that really
wanted to to hear from me and wanted my
support and what happened that was so so
transformational was i woke up one
morning a few days into this and i woke
up at like 5 a.m and i was i was upset
by
the still a little yeah the thought came
right back
and in that moment i was like okay zach
said get on dm so i get back on my dm
and i start dming and i see this girl
and she's talking to me and she's saying
you know listen i um was sober for two
years i just went out i feel like i'm i
want to commit suicide right now i
started dming with her within the hour
i'm on the phone with her
and
that day she made a commitment to go
back to recovery
so i have
deep gratitude for those haters because
those haters gave me this beautiful
opportunity of service to somebody and
potentially save her life
and and and and also just get over it
we're always
able to
lean into two different energies which
is a topic we've spoken about often here
on the show
but when people say oh i want to get
myself into attracting power i want to
manifest more into my life they often
think that it's something that they need
to do like i need to
make a vision board or i need to talk
about it a lot or i need to affirm how i
want to feel or i need to do do do i
need to meditate more i need to
read that book
when really the simplicity is that it's
not so much about what we do
but it's about how we feel
when we feel good we attract more good
into our life that is a core through
line of this show dear gabby it comes up
over and over and over again and this
card as it says when i'm connected to my
joyful presence i attract support from
the universe for me listen i
try to find even the most difficult
circumstances as an opportunity to lean
into something that's a better feeling
vibration so sometimes you may be
thinking well how could i lean into joy
when i'm dealing with a diagnosis or
when i have just lost my job or when i
am having struggles in my marriage or
whatever the problem might be
this is when we really have to get to
work those moments when things are
difficult and there isn't joy in sight
that's when we have to do our best to
lean into the next best feeling
vibration compassion is something we can
throw around very easily oh be
compassionate oh it's compassion that
heals compassion compassion compassion
but what does it mean to actually be
compassionate towards yourself
have you considered the experience of
self-compassion
in your own daily moments or life
experiences have you considered what it
means to
turn that mirror around reflect it back
onto you and say in what ways do i need
to honor myself honor my wounds honor my
feelings and be present with right where
i am in this moment
and through the experience of compassion
i can dissolve all fear and boundaries
i've always thought of compassion as
something that we give to somebody else
that we place upon the world that i
hadn't thought about it about in terms
of compassion towards myself i've been
working with a great great teacher a
woman by the name of kachina myers and
she's been helping me a lot and and
she's teaching me the practice of
self-compassion in my own life
when i witness myself in old stories or
old patterns or if i see myself
triggered or wounded in some way the
first step is to feel what i'm feeling
underneath that wound and then the next
step she's taught me is to just be
loving and compassionate towards myself
so i'll have some type of self-talk
something like this
gabby here's your wound again
you're uncomfortable in this it's all
good here it is it's just presenting
itself to you one more time so you can
get closer to healing
congratulations for having the
willingness and the strength to look at
this wound i love you gabby you are
amazing you are incredible for being
able to show up for this let's move
through this together and i have this
type of dialogue with myself where my
real inner wisdom my highest self can
come to the surface and can show up for
that weak wounded ego part of myself
that is still unable to see the light
and so it's it's having a dialogue of
compassion with yourself when you
witness your wounds that's the simple
practice here so consider this the next
time you see yourself triggered or the
next time you have the
acceptance that your assignment is right
in front of your face again and
simply go into a place of compassion
hold yourself like an innocent child
speak to yourself the same way you would
your own child
and in that dialogue you will come back
to a place of deep deep love
deep compassion and peace because you're
allowing yourself to be wherever you are
in whatever is happening i think that
we all have uh in our own ways
unresolved
wounds from
attachment breach from childhood
experiences from feelings of being
unlovable and not good enough
they will continue to show up for us as
somatic experiences they'll show up in
our lives as gut conditions as
men as as as anxiety disorders they may
show up as insomnia they may show up as
back pain
they will show up until you show up for
them
in my life as a
human but also as a spiritual personal
growth teacher i have been in the
devotional commitment of showing up for
my
my
wounded part so that i can step into the
resourced
healthy whole part of who i am
the journey i've been on is nothing
short of a miracle i've i as you
mentioned earlier i was a drug addict in
my 20s got sober at 25 just through my
own desire to be clean
then in my mid-30s i remembered i
remembered a dissociated traumatic event
from my childhood
that really put me on the path of
understanding why i used in the first
place to really understand why i was a
drug addict and
then really made the devotional
commitment to go further than my
spiritual practice and really start to
develop a therapeutic many therapeutic
practices for
helping myself get back to a healthy
baseline
and for restoring my nervous system and
grounding my energy so that i can be
where i am today lisa which is so
[ __ ] happy
so at ease so healthy and well and i i
wouldn't be able to be in this place now
if i hadn't had the opportunity to
do all the big lifting and heavy lifting
that i experienced before so i'm
grateful for the tough stuff because
it's revealed the great stuff now
everyone that's walking through this
this world every human being
they may not have had to have trauma
like we've had but they're walking
through life
feeling
unsafe
they may not have had sexual abuse or
enough father that abandoned them but
maybe their teacher told them they were
stupid or maybe they you know they like
got lost one day in the parking lot when
they were a kid and didn't find their
mom it doesn't these subtle moments are
as of course in miracles says the
moments that we detour into fear they
call it the descent from magnitude into
littleness and we then create this form
of ego which is a separate mind separate
from god separate from love separate
from that freedom and it builds up a
pretense around us i mean i've been
living in it right now i'm watching a 10
month old child so free of ego so free
of fear and i'm so conscious of every
moment and so conscious of not you know
being on my phone when i'm with him
because i don't want to create look i'm
going to create those moments he's going
to have he's a human having a human
experience but i want to hold him in the
preciousness of this god-like state as
long as possible right but that's not
how people's parents are right
that's not how we grew up right we
we all grow up in this world where
there's just so each moment is an
opportunity to detour into fear and then
we create a world of
fear-based perceptions and so what we
must do to live and thrive and feel good
is undo those fear-based perceptions and
i believe through a spiritual path or
through maybe a therapeutic pet i think
spirits in all of it whether you realize
it or not
but to make a commitment to feel better
it means that you're committed to
returning to god
or love or word you know spiritual
universe
yes you might agree with me on this like
i can in one hour i can do more than the
average person can do in a day or two
days okay and that's because i do things
from inspiration
and so when you're inspired you're in
spirit and you are expanding time you're
given more energy and
you just can get you know every things
download fast and that's the first step
is to really accept that you do have the
power to create the world that you want
to see
and you can totally tweet that because
it's something we've got to share we've
got to put out we've got to know it and
that first step of knowing it is really
probably the most crucial step in the
creative visualization process
the next step is to really just begin to
suspend disbelief begin to look at the
things that you want to create and take
all that disbelief and reorganize it
reprogram it change your perception
around it because when we're in that
story of disbelief that's what we're
creating so take a minute to really look
at all the disbelief and find a way to
reframe it but reframe it in a way that
you believe it so if you've got
disbelief that you could never lose that
weight start to reframe it with a belief
system that's that's truthful to you
that's natural to you something along
the lines of
i believe that i can get to the gym
every day and that's my first step i
believe that i have the power to eat
more healthfully so leaning into a
belief system that is
real for you that you can actually hold
on to that you can actually believe in
because if you start to use affirmations
and reframes that you don't believe in
they won't work that's just the bottom
line they won't work so reach for
thoughts that you believe in
and then the next step is to sit in a
daily experience of visualization
visualize yourself going to that gym
visualize yourself in that healthy body
visualize yourself eating that healthy
meal and chewing it slowly or visualize
yourself on that date with that partner
that you long for or visualize yourself
working with the people that you love to
work with that support you so much
and then the next and final
most important step is to allow that
visualization to become a feeling let
that visualization take over you
emotionally so you can genuinely feel a
connection to what you're seeing
so i allow my mind to wander and i see
myself and what it is that i desire and
then i let the feeling take over the
feeling of being taken care of the
feeling of being supported the feeling
of working and co-creating with people
that i love and that's what i'm
currently visualizing and so being in
that feeling is what truly manifests
this into form
what's most awesome also is that you
start to feel what you want to create
even before it comes into form so it's
as if it's already happened and that's
actually the key point here which is
that you being in the energy of what it
is that you want to create actually
makes it so that it is there even if you
can't see it and you got to believe it
before you see it as my teacher dr wayne
dyer always said
so take these steps suspend disbelief
choose to reframe those stories and see
them in a really high vibe affirmation
bring that thought and that vision into
the creative visualization process where
you sit in stillness in your meditation
and allow your mind to wander and see
visions of what you really want to call
in
and then be in the feeling of what it is
that you desire the voice within us that
believes that we are not allowed to be
happy
our card today is speaking to that
i believe i'm worthy of feeling good i
believe i am worthy of feeling good
this is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice but it's
actually far from our reality
because many of us have been brought up
with the belief system that we have to
suffer to succeed that we have to feel
pain to have purpose that we have to
have struggles in order to
feel a sense of serenity in our life
that is all quite backwards
it's when we feel good that we actually
attract more of what we want into our
life but we have to undo the belief
system that says who am i to feel good
who am i to feel great who am i to be
happy that belief system is an ingrained
belief system that can be cultural that
can be something that we learned from
our upbringing it can be something that
we have picked up from this difficult
experience that we're going through
right now with kovid when we witness
people suffering we think well how dare
i be happy i would say to you how dare
you not be happy it's your happiness
it's the collective happiness it's the
group collective happiness that raises
the energetic frequency of the world if
we those of us who have moments of
happiness and grace and joy and success
and we don't celebrate them we are doing
the world a disservice we are shutting
down the light we are bringing down the
vibration so we have to when we feel
good we have to reach for more when we
feel good we have to recognize that that
good feeling emotion has momentum it has
power it elevates our children it
elevates our family members it elevates
our friends it elevates strangers on the
street it is your divine duty here on
earth to bring forth that greatness that
goodness that light so when you hear
that voice that says to you you are not
worthy of feeling good i want you to
hear my voice come through and say to
you
who are you not to feel good
this is your divine purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me
we are more comfortable being
uncomfortable than we are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a
solution happiness oriented mindset so
when that happens the next time you
notice that you're feeling good and all
is well and all of a sudden you're like
but i wasn't nice enough to that person
or my coworkers aren't in a good place
or i didn't do that right i want you to
speak back to that voice i want you to
say thank you for sharing but i choose
happiness instead
thank you for sharing but i don't
believe that voice anymore thank you for
sharing but i'm choosing this moment
give yourself permission in the moment
to speak back to the fault-finding voice
and start to claim the greatness of who
you are that is a pattern because you've
lived your life in a habitual pattern of
seeking problems and finding fault now
we have to redirect and create a new
habit and pattern of grounding you in
the truth of who you are which is
happiness joy peace and
grace sharing that happiness joy and
peace with so much grace
that's what you're here for not only do
i talk about spirit guides and angels
and deceased family members but i also
talked about your higher self so this is
to woo for you
start to tap into what is the voice of
my higher self gotcha right that voice
of my inner guidance system and that
wisdom that i believe in is my is my
true nature right
but i i personally gabby bernstein i
believe that i that we all have
guides ancestors family members teachers
beings of uh light beings energy beings
that are supporting us in a in a form
that is is uh able to step in able to
channel through us when we write books
able to to be there in those darkest
moments pick us up off the floor uh and
and and hold us in in discomfort and
guide us to
business opportunities or babies or
whatever it is that we're looking for
and it's always available to us that
guidance but we just we cut it off we
block it
why do we block the guidance fear is the
reason we block it fear
it's not even fear it's that false based
perception that we've built up around
ourselves from those traumatic events
right so we have these traumatic events
early in life and they continue to build
and build and build we build up a world
of false perceptions i am this body i am
gabby bernstein i am lewis howe i've got
the school of great people
i can't trust people we we create these
beliefs and you believe you're separate
from others you believe you're you're
better than or less than or not good
enough and all those stories all those
those false pretenses are what what many
spiritual
practices called the ego right and that
fear-based perception of yourself is
misaligned with with with god with love
with spirit with angels with guides and
so this book is all about how to get
back into alignment so that you can hear
that guidance and receive that guidance
and be a
channel for inspiration and when you
when you clear
and undo those patterns of fear and
start to claim the pattern of love
that's when you are
hooked up super attractor
unstoppable unstoppable invisible door
is open for you it doesn't matter how
low you are when you're starting this
you will go way further than you could
possibly have imagined any desire that
we have that we strangle
we will block
you also have a desire that does involve
another person
very intimately
and he may not be there with you yet
so
this is all the more reason for you to
really settle down and step back and
truly surrender
so
while you may not have had the same
story as me of really
struggling to conceive
you're at a place of
struggling to embrace
or welcome
or even agree to it's like a third child
so
the steps that i lay out in my oprah
super soul sessions talk
the spiritual steps to
surrender or for anyone that is holding
on to a desire so tightly that they
think they're getting in the way of it
the first step is to take your hands off
the wheel through prayer
so let's do that today
right now
the secret to prayer is to forget what
you think you need
when you start to pray for what's of the
highest good rather than
what you think you need
then the universe can take over
you are feeling the presence of a spirit
baby it's not just your longing it's the
baby's longing
to trust that
talk to the baby let the baby show you
signs
be in the inquiry of that relationship
even though it's not in form yet
but most importantly right now being in
the prayer of what is of the highest
good for all for your husband for you
for your children for the baby
because your plan is not a good plan
honey not you everybody our plans are
[ __ ]
the universe has a plan far better than
we do so i want you to really ground
yourself in
the
belief and understanding that you don't
call the shots especially truthfully you
just in the human form you can't you
have a husband who is an equal partner
in this parenting and you don't want to
force that or trick them into it or you
know you just you can't like it's just
not it's just not right so um you got to
be in the full-blown surrender go to
youtube watch or go to my website and
watch the super soul sessions talk with
oprah all the steps are there but that
first step and the steps are also in the
universe has your back but the other
step of the spiritual path to surrender
is really to take your hands off the
wheel
and and through prayer
say show me what you got have more
freaking fun gabby have
more fun stop being so serious stop
being so so uh so obsessed and stop
being so scared have more fun the secret
to manifesting the career beyond our
wildest dreams is to have more fun fun
is the catalyst for all that we create
in life fun is the catalyst for all the
joy that we bring forth fun is the
key ingredient to being a super
attractor
now if you're a spiritual entrepreneur
and you want more guidance from me on
this topic i have a beautiful pdf
download called 10 ways to succeed as a
spiritual entrepreneur i just can't
emphasize enough the power of the
practices in this pdf it will give you
this clear direction on
the
methods that i applied in my own
spiritual entrepreneurial path
to really set myself free and to show up
with grace and to create a movement
behind my message i recently had a bit
of a conflict with a friend and it kind
of pissed me off it was like i felt like
i was being attacked and i didn't like
how it was handled and i walked away in
what would be a very normal human
response which is to feel defensive and
want to fight back and want to just in
my case i'm such a scorpio i want to
just be like screw you it's over but i i
know that's not who i am it's not my
highest self so i i lean on my tools and
i started to just meditate on this and
what i started to hear in my meditation
was accept them where they are
and recognizing that maybe people may
not be showing up the way that you want
them to
and they may not be treating you exactly
how you want them to but when you can
accept them where they are accept them
in the experience that they are having
then you can let go you can forgive and
you can release
accepting someone where they are doesn't
necessarily mean you stick around
especially if it's a abusive situation
or something that is not serving your
highest good but it is giving you the
freedom to walk away with grace because
you're an acceptance of who they are and
where they are and so what does this
mean it means really simply look at
these relationships and rather than
getting into a defensive state and
feeling like we need to be right and
feeling like we need to prove that we've
got everything on our side and that we
have nothing to do with how the
circumstances are going forward
instead it's it's just taking ownership
of our own happiness and choosing to see
that this person is in a situation that
is not
necessarily well or not necessarily
happy or not necessarily fully complete
and accepting that's where they're at so
here's the practice it's really simple
just looking at the situation as it is
taking yourself and your experience of
being a victim out of the story and just
looking at this person in whatever is up
for them and saying i accept you where
you are
in that you can make a decision of how
you want to move forward you can decide
i'm done i got to take care of myself i
need to take some space or you can make
a decision to say you know what i i'd
like to clear this let's let's talk it
through i want to hear what's up for you
but you create the opportunity for
freedom and healing when you accept
someone where they are there was one
thing i heard backstage that just blew
my mind i fell off my chair and it was
when deepak shared that when you're
happy for some reason
you're still in misery because that
reason can be taken from you tomorrow
and so really just centered me and wow
if i'm happy for some reasons in my life
that i'm actually still in misery think
about that it's amazingly beautiful
topic that just really got me right back
into that centered right-sized place
focusing on letting go of what i think i
need
because when we focus on what we think
we need that's when we really disconnect
from our our true connection to god and
our true connection to the universe
uh of course a miracle says that the
secret to prayer is to forget what you
think you need
so when we can get over these ideas of
this thing will make me happy or this
accomplishment is why i am at peace and
we can start to really focus our energy
every single day and being in that
present moment being in the stillness of
our meditation maybe one second one
glimpse of connection through a prayer
and not praying for what we think we
need but praying for the highest good
for all
we can start to build up a little bit
more of that spiritual mojo a little bit
more of that
mindful connection and it's our job not
necessarily to just go from from being
focused on the goals of the world to
immediately tomorrow just denouncing
everything and just being completely
connected to love but our goal more
importantly is to
be in
the moment-to-moment practice of letting
go of goals and objectives and being
focused on happiness peace and serenity
and connection and oneness being our
intention and
that shift will help you reframe how you
experience
all the things that you think you need
all the accomplishments all the the
support all the security all the stuff
that you think you need to feel safe
can be something that you experience as
a result
of the great spiritual condition that
you have rather than something that you
chase after in order to feel that safe
condition i think the most important
step here is that the condition comes
first and the
beautiful experiences that you have in
life will always be a reflection of your
grounded committed and connected
spiritual condition
so take that in let go of what you think
you need maybe you want to post in the
comments below what you're willing to
release
and your commitment to surrendering and
then even surrendering more what i would
say to you my love is to make sure that
your focus is not on what's not working
you know the job loss i need to make
money but
focusing on what is working what is
thriving and so in this moment what's
thriving is you know that there's a
place in the world that you want to go
that's a really big deal
and you
have these children who you have set off
into the world in such a magnificent way
and they are so steady and strong and
have such great jobs and such great
future and you can be so proud of
that the universe has given you an
opening an opening to step out and do
something new
and so your job my friend is to stay
super connected to what feels good so
that you can listen to that voice of
inner wisdom that's going to show you
where to go and what to do
that voice of wisdom can't come when
we're stuck in what can i do how can i
do this i'm afraid to tell my kids i
don't want them to worry here's the deal
that was smart not to tell them because
look i don't believe in withholding
information from people but you with
sometimes we don't want to let people in
on something when we're still triggered
by it so now when you get off this this
dear gabby with me and you get yourself
into that alignment of this is actually
a major opportunity that's the place to
tell them from hey guys great news lost
my job moving to colorado got a really
big opportunity for something new in
front of me i don't think i would have
done this if i hadn't lost the job the
universe has my back okay hear me hear
me hear me hear me that stop let's this
is this is a here i don't have any doubt
that you're a practical woman that's
going to take practical action that's
going to put her resume out there that's
going to make some calls it's going to
get her out i mean you're a hustler
right i see it you know you were a
single mom with young children you made
that [ __ ] happen okay so i don't have
any any any doubt that you're going to
do the things that you need to do in the
world to get a job
but i'm not here as your
career counselor i'm here as your
spiritual counselor to make sure that
whatever you do to go get that job is
from a place that's grounded in the
alignment of love and the universe and
the truth of who you are which is the
magnificence of who you are the
magnificence of spirit within you so
go do all the practical things you need
to do to find that job to attract that
job to apply for that job maybe the
first job isn't in colorado maybe the
first job is just be open to creative
possibility sister my job is a spiritual
tune-up for you right now to just take
the word challenge off the table and get
into opportunity
now
that place of opportunity is gonna hook
you up to be
fully fully fully guided every single
step of the way my true safety lies in
my capacity to align with the love of
the universe that's our message for
today i'm not even going to say a single
word more vowel that is your message i
believe it's come through for you as
your spiritual counselor go
feel into the feeling of what it feels
like to be in colorado to be in that
abundance to be free to be driving in
that rv
and you know how to take practical
action but make sure that it's aligned
with spiritual force
i'm going to send you a copy of super
attractor i want you to read the whole
chapter on how to
take spiritually aligned action
and manifest a life beyond her wildest
dreams it just never ceases to amaze me
that the
guidance that comes through with the
card is always
the exact message that needs to come
through on the show for each person each
guest that's coming through here this is
a spiritual reinvention
today how to reinvent yourself through
your spiritual practice
i
am so moved by
the love that comes through each guest
i'm so moved by the love that comes
through my spirit guides i thank you for
holding me in that i want to be more
unapologetic about that relationship and
that wisdom because
i've never felt alone on my stages or as
i write my books or doing this podcast
i'm not alone in this work i want to
really acknowledge the
guidance and the support system that's
always around me it's like a big posse
of spiritual guides that are around me
supporting me to do this work
and i really welcome them to be a
presence on this show
and to become more unapologetic about it
because there is that voice in me that
wants to say oh my god this might be too
weird for somebody but i gotta trust
that you guys
landed here for a reason
and we all have that voice of spiritual
connection that love within us that
truth within us that confidence within
us that adult resourced self within us
that is begging to come through
the more we lean into that presence the
more we lean into this spiritual
conversation the easier it is to allow
ourselves to be led
to stop controlling and start allowing
and to trust everything that's unfolding
in front of us
for anyone out there today who resonated
with this idea that we have this
feeling of who am i
who am i who am i
this is your answer today
you are a spirit among spirits
your mission is to align with the energy
of love and express that love in your
own unique ways
and that is the answer
never question it
never deny it
and you will live a life beyond your
wildest dreams for our audience can you
define what exactly is manifesting
manifesting is acquiring the experience
of what it is that you want to feel and
being and living and believing in that
experience and then allowing that
experience to come into form manifesting
is very creative it is the process of
using your power energy and being in
that presence of your high-powered
energy and allowing that energy to
co-create with the energy that's around
you so you're vibrating at a high
frequency i'm vibrating at high
frequency we've done a lot of work we've
cleaned up a lot of our own crap we
believe in ourselves today and that that
energy of believing in ourselves has
attracted us together today and brought
us into the space where we together are
co-creating and teaching if i hadn't
cleaned up my side of the street and if
i didn't believe in myself the way i do
i would never have manifested being on
marietv there's a really nice line from
a course in miracles which is the
metaphysical text i teach and it is
miracles occur naturally and when
they're not occurring something has gone
wrong
that's interesting it's a good one right
so what happens is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh i
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be
we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our anxiety our our
anger towards the past that future
tripping and projecting all of that
energy gets in the way of allowing all
of the miracles to occur naturally i
have a very important lesson that's
something i've been applying in my own
life and a girlfriend of mine called me
yesterday and she said that she was
feeling really attacked and judged by
someone at work and my response was
don't defend yourself don't fight back
don't judge back
your work i said to her is to
the moment that you feel judged and
attacked
do something
immediately
to make somebody else feel loved so when
you feel as though someone has attacked
you judged you bullied you doing
anything to make you feel inadequate or
unlovable
do the opposite do the exact opposite go
and do something to make other people
feel good so go make somebody feel
lovable adequate and good enough and
that
simple practice of just
taking yourself out of the knee-jerk
reaction to to fight back or defend but
instead to go give love that can change
everything for you so i wanted to give
you this message i'm going to have to
hang up on you in a moment because i'm
going to make dinner but that is my
lesson for you today when you feel
judged immediately go give love go do
something kind do something
compassionate do something loving that
will be the quickest way to stop the
momentum of the negative energy there
are way too many haters out there
there's so much negativity there's so
much bullying and there's so much attack
and judgment and that's why i wrote an
entire book about this topic so my hope
for you is that when you feel judged or
attacked instead of attacking back you
go give love you do something to make
somebody feel good you do something
that's based in compassion and love and
joy you make somebody you make someone
feel good about themselves what's the
first step to overcoming the fear or
transforming the fear
to witness it to be to be the
non-judgmental witness of it
to look at it and say
something's got to give right so so
if you're unwilling to look at your fear
head-on and honor it and and witness i
always say if you don't show up for
what's up it will keep showing up
so looking and saying you know i witness
my resistance and you see that fear as
resistance it's right it's it's fear is
the resistance to what it is that you
desire
and in the absence of resistance you
become a magnet for what you desire you
know when you let go of that fear and
you transcend that fear that's when you
start to become a super attractor that's
when you start to let what is truly
uh of essence for you into your life
what is truly of service for you into
your life what is true happiness into
your life and so
looking at the fear witnessing it
calling it by its name and even if you
don't have the tools yet what happens is
when you look at the fear and you're
like oh i see this fear i see this
resistance i see how it's blocking my
life and i choose to see it differently
that's when you're listening to an audio
like this that's when a book like yours
will fall off the shelf a catalyst yeah
exactly you open up your consciousness
pretty much you crack open your
consciousness to find solutions rather
than find problems and so when you're
not looking at the fear you're just
living in the fear and you're believing
in the problem but when you witness the
fear and you're willing to see it
differently you start living in a
solution as i commit to happiness fully
exactly what i need is coming towards me
because i become a magnet i become an
energy field that is so
magnetizing that is so excited that so
inspired that other people want to
support and work with that energy and so
when we dwell in the energy of joy and
happiness we become a magnet for that
which we desire
so my hope for you all is to start to
think about the things that you want to
succeed in whether it's succeeding in
romantic relationships or succeeding in
your career or succeeding in your health
goals and make a commitment today to
bring more joy
to that area of your life rather than
seeing it as a struggle rather than
pushing forward with all this angst and
negativity and neediness and control
just bring joy to it
your successes will come when you commit
to joy when you commit to happiness so
find more joy in that physical exercise
i've been going a soul cycle i
absolutely love it it's so joyful for me
and that's helping me raise my butt
because that was one of my goals and
success and and then we have these
moments where we want to really bring
joy into our career well if you're
having a hard time in the office just
find ways to have more fun
and as we start to elevate that presence
of joy we will begin to magnetize the
successes in our life and so take this
very seriously bring this practice into
your day-to-day experiences and make joy
and happiness your number one priority
and recognize how your successes will be
brought to you in a form far greater
than you could ever imagine when your
primary focus is happiness now if you're
resenting somebody else you're really
just unconsciously resenting yourself
so witnessing very quickly
who do i need to forgive is it me is it
somebody else and very quickly turning
it back on to you and choosing the
pathway of forgiveness forgiving
yourself for having a judgmental thought
forgiving yourself for being in attack
forgiving yourself for having a feeling
that is unkind forgiving yourself for
being judgmental towards yourself or
attacking towards yourself whatever is
up for you in the moment just practice
the f word and if you can't get to the
feeling of forgiving yourself
say that you are willing to forgive
yourself just saying in that moment i'm
willing to forgive myself for xyz
i'm willing to forgive myself for being
in this bad mood i'm willing to forgive
myself for what i just said i'm willing
to forgive myself for what i'm holding
on to and just opening yourself up to
the practice of self-forgiveness will
change your mood and your energy in a
minute or less
i i swear by this this is probably the
key to my freedom my happiness my
successes is my willingness to forgive
myself
so take that in and and really own that
for you and practice the f word all the
time so the next time you notice
yourself in a bad mood it might just be
right in this moment right now
just say i'm willing to forgive myself
and and see what unfolds see how your
energy changes see how your your
feelings begin to shift and see that bad
mood just dissipate instantly really
really feel what it would feel like to
be in the action of what it is that you
are dreaming of and what does that feel
like to be
the on the career path that is your
dream or what does it feel like to be
doing the work in the world that you've
been so longing to bring forth or what
does it feel like to be spreading an
empowering message in a unique and
innovative way and in the process of
gathering those feelings we do it
through meditation
sit in your meditation for two to three
minutes a day and just allow yourself to
cultivate the feeling of what it is that
you desire
i have had many experiences throughout
my life where i've just allowed myself
to be in the feeling of service or in
the feeling of excitement of seeing
myself on a stage or in the feeling of
seeing myself sitting next to oprah and
doing an interview and all of those
emotional feelings that came forth in my
meditations became the manifestations of
my life so take very seriously the
thoughts and the feelings there's always
a spiritual assignment there's always
something to learn there's always an
opportunity for growth in all
relationships particularly romantic
relationships
but when that learning
is no longer
happening when
one person's growing and the other
person isn't
when there is a
leap spiritually and the other person is
not leaping with
there can be a
disconnect in the learning opportunity
the
idea that we could be
forcing a relationship if you have a
sense that you're forcing a relationship
it's likely that you are it doesn't mean
that the relationship isn't right it
means that you are trying to make it
right rather than allowing it to show
you what's right rather than
trying to make someone who you think
they should be
allow them to teach you
who you really are here to step into not
teach you but reflect back to you who
you are here to step into
rather than
trying to change someone else
put the mirror back on yourself and say
what is it within me that is ready to
develop more what is it within me that
is ready to grow more if you show up
like that and you keep growing and you
keep rising up and they don't rise with
you there's your answer
if you keep focusing your side of the
street keeping your side of the street
clean what is it that i got to work
through here how can i show up more and
they say oh okay i'm going to be a
reflection of her new shift and i'm
going to grow as a result of her growth
and i'm going to be new because of this
development within her then you are both
energetically growing together if you're
here and he's not growing with
there's your answer there's your answer
you know if you're trying to force him
to get here with you you are forcing the
relationship put the focus right back on
top to you
change your inner work your inner life
reflecting that mirror back onto
yourself
and if he starts to vibrate at a higher
frequency as you do you know the answer
when you notice that you're in that
story and that trauma of your you know
negativity fear or judgment attack
that's making you feel bad notice it
notice the thought right away
and then you say how is this thought
making me feel
that's step one notice the thought and
how is it making me feel
and the second step is to forgive
yourself for having the thought not
beating yourself up why am i i used to
do this all my life why am i having such
an idiot why am i so stupid why can't i
figure this out what is wrong with you
that was my pattern for years i know i
know
so how do we get out of that forgive
yourself for having the thought forgive
the thought if you can't forgive
yourself for having thought because that
just feels too heavy for you just
forgive the thought like okay that's
that's that thought again
that's from my childhood trauma that's
from mike's you know my fear of this
that's from whatever there it is again
and then the third step is to start to
proactively choose again
and this is where we begin to reach for
the next best feeling thought we reach
for this is a um very influenced by
abraham hicks which is written you know
mentioned 23 times in that book what was
it called like the purge of appreciation
or something else
rampage of appreciation yeah so one
you're going to choose again in that
third step you're going to reach for a
thought that you believe in so what if
you don't believe in any good thoughts
you you have you have a thought that
could be better and here's here's what
it could be it could be
i
can turn on lewis howe's podcast right
now and that might make me feel better
that that's a that's a thought right
right or i have that book that i could
open a page too and maybe it will give
me inspiration or you know just
something as simple as like i'm gonna go
for a walk for five minutes that might
make me feel bad right so and then you
keep going you keep reaching for it so
you reach for the thought
uh i'm gonna go for a walk i'm gonna let
myself feel better then you go you know
you go for that walk and uh i'm gonna
just listen to some music that music
might make me feel better or the next
thought could be i actually have dinner
tonight with my friends so that will be
great and i can bring myself to that but
little things like my credit card got
stolen and i'm on the phone with the
credit card company and i'm i'm trying
to get out of the hotel with my son and
i have a nanny with me so like my
nanny's like oh the baby pooped you know
i'm on the phone with the credit card
company there's no uber in santa fe and
the baby's pooped and you're just like
you know these moments and so i started
going into the i'm out of control
so i notice it really quickly now
i witnessed the thought
i forgive myself for acting out and
being rude to the woman at the credit
card company and then i choose again
okay let's change the poopy diaper let's
get in the car
at this moment yes i could have carried
that negative thing all the way down to
santa fe having lunch but i decided to
turn it around quickly yeah and that's
how we can we can start to live like
that there's no such thing as a mistake
everything happens in divine order i am
being guided to learn and grow here we
go people
when we look at the situations in our
life from a place of regret
we ultimately miss the opportunity for
growth
we miss the opportunity to see what
could have been
beneath that discomfort we miss the
opportunity to acknowledge and recognize
that every experience in our life is not
an accident it doesn't happen by
accident it happens in a divine order
and when we live and lead and show up
for our life
grounded in that belief system then we
can face our most difficult moments
with a
sense of purpose and power
and we can show up for those moments
with a opportunity to grow focusing on
the opportunity to grow focusing on the
opportunity for a shift for strength for
spiritual awakening for a new way of
being a new perception of our lives so
that's a lot i know that's a lot i know
that when something really bad happens
like what we've been experiencing
recently in the world what we
experienced in the united states last
week when we experienced something like
a pandemic we don't want to see the
spiritual assignment we don't want to
see that this is not a mistake
but typically when difficult things
happen they are revealing what needs to
be healed these uncomfortable moments
whether they be global or they be
personal are revealing what we have to
heal whether we have to heal it on an
individual level which is where it
begins and what we have to heal on a
global perspective on a global level so
showing up to all these uncomfortable
moments and recognizing them that they
are not a mistake that they are
happening in a divine order and it's our
opportunity to perceive these situations
from the lens of what can i learn from
this how can i grow from this how can i
shift from this how can i lean towards
more love how can i lean towards more
joy how can i lean into the lesson
rather than the problem the solution
rather than seeking all of the faults
and and looking for all of the problems
so i'm in this three-year journey of
trying to conceive and
really for a year and a half almost two
years i was like in the low of it really
feeling like okay i'm not good enough my
body isn't working how can i make this
happen how can i make this happen right
and really pushing and controlling and
trying to eat things and
track my ovulation and all that crap
and then about the fall of 2017 i
started to get into more of a
surrendered state and i started
practicing the methods that i teach in
the book of just really
trusting that there
was
a
higher guidance that i believed in for
my whole life and relying on that and
that's when things started to get really
wild and synchronistic and so around the
fall of 2017 i was driving in the
countryside where i live most of the
time and this is where i do the majority
of my manifesting it's just driving in
the car
looking at the foliage listening to my
mantra music and i feel so awesome when
i'm in that position and i'm just so
grateful in the moment and i'm driving
and i'm driving i'm like i feel so
awesome and so grateful that i live in
this country town i have all these
friends and i don't have any cell
service right now and i'm so psyched
about that and no one's bothering me and
i feel good and then all of a sudden i
felt the presence of a baby in the back
seat
and i was like wow like deeply moved
tears started to roll down my face i
felt so moved
and at that point i heard my intuition
say to me
the baby's coming in march
and i was like and it was so loud like
you know when you hear the voice of your
inspiration you're like that's it okay i
believe and so i started saying to
myself over and over like oh my god
march you know i have to conceive at
this time for the baby to come and watch
i saw myself getting a little into it
like too into it and hooked into it so i
said okay listen you know what universe
i'm gonna give this over
and if my baby is indeed coming in march
show me a sign
show me lily's to let me know that the
baby's coming in march
and a week later i got a letter in the
mail from a reader and it had this angel
card in it and on the back of it was
this picture of archangel gabriel and
archangel gabriel is typically depicted
holding lilies so i was like yo this is
dope and on the back he wrote
i thought that you needed this i was
like thank you good so here i am march
march is coming march is happening and
early march rolled around and i wasn't
pregnant so i was like what the hell and
not only was i devastated once again
another month has gone by i'm not
pregnant but this time i was like i
thought the universe had my back like i
was getting signs like what what's the
uh what's up
so i walked into my husband's office and
i was just hysterically crying so upset
so defeated
and at some my phone was like on the
desk like right here
and all of a sudden my phone started
playing a song
and the song was just repeating
repeating it's like go like you know
when your phone malfunctions you're like
i'm just gonna turn that off i was like
okay i'm just gonna turn it out and then
i look at the phone and i start
listening to the lyrics and the lyrics
are way go lily
way go lily and the guy keeps repeating
way go lily and then i look even further
and i look at the name of the song as
way go lily and he keeps repeating lily
and i look even further and the album
title is i see the sign
and where was this playing where what
area of your phone this was just my
phone just turned on oh wow no that's
you know it's spirit working through the
technology and so my phone just turned
on it was an album that i'd never heard
i'd never heard the song before it
wasn't in my spotify and it just began
playing now get this
so i get i april rolls around and i'm
pregnant
but then i did the math and i was like
when did i conceive
i conceived the last day of march
so that
synchronicity you know you hear march
you find your signs you feel super
guided that synchronicity is available
to all of us but it's when it had we
have to get out of that pusher mentality
and out of that controlling behavior to
allow the presence of spirit to work
through us and guide us and or the
universe or whatever use whatever you
call it to be the presence of of of
direction inspiration
to be that guide the appreciation
dissolves the boundary of fear
and appreciation creates more of what
you want
so if you've got something good going on
go appreciate it even more talk about it
thrive in it write about it feel it
meditate on the feeling of it because
then you create more of it if you're in
a funk lean on what you appreciate to
get you out of that funk and make
appreciation a daily habit you know like
when you and josh go wake up in the
morning
abraham hicks has this thing called the
appreciation game where you can just
play the appreciation game and just say
i appreciate you because you make me
coffee and i appreciate you because
you're a good dancer and i'm just
thinking about you enjoying it
because you're so funny on television
whatever it is you know but just just
really appreciating your spouse your
children and and play that game with
your children oh my goodness start your
day going back and forth with why you
appreciate one another and it
immediately just realigns you puts you
into this state where you feel so good
because how can you if you can't feel
bad in the presence of appreciation yeah
and it will catapult you out of the
negativity and that's what this is all
about this is all about taking these
moments and using these methods and
these practices to consciously and
proactively bridge yourself from that
low vibration to a better feeling
emotion and in that better feeling
emotion you become a super attractor you
know i went on my instagram and i was
like how many of you i did a a poll and
i said how many of you are blocking
you're manifesting and 96 percent said
yes
yeah and there's and i call it out i
caught the ways that we block and i and
this whole book is methods for
unblocking
and and the thing is is that you know
the thing that's most important is if to
trust that if you're watching this right
now that you are in in fact being guided
so even if you don't feel that guidance
you can hear that inspiration there's no
way that you would have listened to this
specific podcast in this specific moment
if you were not indeed being guided
okay so just take that in fully and
completely and then your next step is to
recognize the guidance and then follow
the guidance you receive whether it's
read this book or not this book maybe
another book maybe after this podcast
you're led to another author on your
podcast and then that's the book that
you need or that's the the therapist
that you need to find it doesn't have to
be me but but but stay open and when
when you have an intuition to listen to
a podcaster it's when you're feeling
free and you make a decision to do
something it's when you're in a place of
of of
you know no agenda
just a place of joy inspiration
relaxation
and you start to listen to something or
a guy just that's that's when you're
really listening that's when you're
really receiving guidance so i think
anyone that's listening to you is
listening but they just may not realize
it listen
i now have deep appreciation for that
dark hole i was in six months ago
because it's giving me an opportunity to
sit here with you today and hopefully
save some lives yeah if there's a mother
out there that's watching and she's
having suicidal thoughts or she's having
panic attacks or she's having insomnia
that she can now go and talk to her
obgyn or her psychiatrist i am deeply
grateful for for everything i've been
through through my addiction recovery
from my trauma healing through physical
things that i've talked about publicly
because they've given me a greater level
of compassion
for what people for the human condition
and a greater much greater opportunity
to speak and teach from a place of
authenticity yeah so that's my
my appreciation for what has been and i
think if we start to look at the
difficult times in our lives and
appreciate them and also recognize them
as a learning device saying okay thank
you
alcoholism or thank you you know fear or
thank you drama in my life right now
because you're revealing to me what i
still need to heal so look everyone has
unresolved areas where they are out of
alignment due to their upbringing their
belief systems from childhood
experiential belief systems whatever has
been imprinted
so some people might be health some
people might be sex some people it might
be money some people it might be their
worth some people might be all of the
above whatever we've all got it we've
all got an area or many where we are
misaligned with
the feeling of love and abundance and
and grace
that's normal that's natural that's
where it's at and just because you fall
into those belief systems and feel into
that frequency from time to time doesn't
mean that you are
doing anything wrong it's that you are
your awareness of it is actually major
okay
so
the undoing of the lac mentality is a
journey of clearing
the belief systems from a experiential
time in your life right that happens
once again through books like the
universe has your back so fantastic that
you're doing that transform fear to
faith
excellent work
it comes through therapeutic practices
like we've been talking about today it
comes through mental reconditioning and
here's the good news we all have these
conditioned neural pathways
from the experiences that we've had as
children particularly young childhood
experiences but the good news is thanks
to neuroplasticity
our brain actually can
change
our brain can reorganize our brain can
become new our fight flight responses
can subside our ptsd can dissolve our
lack mentality can turn into an
abundance mentality we our brain has the
power to change and so much of that
change happens with the repetition of
new behavior so one thing that you can
do simply in this moment is to notice
when you are in that lac mentality
notice how it makes you feel
forgive the thought
and choose again
and this is a method i've shared over
and over and over again on this show the
choose again method because
yes i could say to all of you go do 10
years of therapy which everyone i hope
will have the opportunity to do whatever
that form that comes but
what you can do for yourself you're here
for self-help you're here for gabby to
tell me how i can serve myself you can
be in the proactive development of new
thought patterns that feel better
not fat patterns that you don't believe
in but thought patterns that make you
feel better
so when you notice that lack story show
up step one notice the thought and how
it makes you feel
step two forgive yourself for having the
thought it's very simple up there's my
childhood story there's my parents lack
story again up there it is again
all right i forgive myself just showed
up again because that forgiveness will
dissolve that guilt and tension and fear
that you're manifesting it all that crap
right
third step
choose the next best feeling thought
choose the thought of you know what i
just forgave myself for that thought so
i'm dissolving it in this moment i
actually am listening to the universe
has your back and it's so supportive
then i can actually go and listen to
super attractor so you can go from
thought to thought to thought to reach
for the next best feeling thought so
your willingness to face this lack
mentality is already activating
abundance within you
right and especially if you're feeling
afraid that you're manifesting things
because you're having the thoughts then
just forgive the thoughts because or
forgive yourself for having the thought
because the moment that you say oh i
forgive myself for that thought or i
forgive that thought
it doesn't have power over you anymore
because you've recognized i am not that
thought it's just a thought that i keep
thinking i am not that belief it's just
a thought that i keep thinking and then
the next question i have for you is when
you're thinking about manifestation and
calling in new things are some of you
manic manifesting so this is really
important
are some of you those folks who are like
i've got the list i've got the vision
board i've said it a thousand times i
told all my friends i want him i know
exactly what he looks like and i feel
like he's with me and we're walking down
the street together holding hands
you know who you are
you know who you are right you know
exactly who you are
look there's nothing wrong with being
clear
there's nothing wrong with being clear
but more importantly i want you to be
clear about how you want to feel and i
want you to just feel it
it's not about having the vision board
that's perfect it's not about having the
most amazing list you can do all that
work you can get clear you can be and if
anyone has a note of vision board it's a
beautiful board where you put all of
your images of what you want and plenty
of people spend a lot of time on that
board but they don't get into the energy
of what it feels like
and so they spend a lot of time with the
list they spend a lot of time with the
board and they spend a lot of time
talking about it but they don't assume
the energy of what it feels like to be
in that manifestation now
assuming the energy of what it felt like
to pop off all your tops
really helped me call in something that
will help me do it
assuming that energy just brought me
into a state of being you are already
there sister you are already doing this
exactly as you are on your video blogs
in your lectures on twitter and facebook
you are already there and you want more
but you are already there
so acknowledging and accepting that i'm
already in the place that i am even
though i want it to be more i am already
there
so if you want a romantic partner
make sure you have a real hot romance
with yourself
if you want more money
make sure you have a real good
relationship with the money you
currently have
if you want a new job make sure you have
a real good relationship with the job
you have today
everybody get that
people think oh well if i appreciate my
job that i have now then i'll only stay
there no absolutely not if you
appreciate the job that you have now
then you show up to that job with grace
you show up that to that job with a good
attitude you show up that job with a
better approach you show up to that job
with more energy that job begins to
thank you that job says wait maybe
there's another job for you that job
then says here you're promoted here's
some more money have a great life
you
create your reality your intentions
create your reality so if you are
constantly in a place of thinking i hate
this i hate this i hate this you are
serving that
everybody's with me now i know you are
so rather than focusing on that manic
manifesting first and foremost get
honest if you are one of them if you are
please raise your hands now manic
manifesters just get honest people
get your hands up
manic manifesto so you're reading the
books you're doing the work you think
you think you think but your energy
what's your energy like scream it to me
what's your energy like
frantic
what was that
when you're saying when got it yes okay
what is your energy saying when your
energy is needy right it's controlling
it's manipulative
it's frightened
it's chaotic
what does that girl look like on a date
so what is your energy doing how is your
manic manifesting affecting your genuine
manifestation
so i want you to get clear about that
and then the next piece here is just to
become super conscious and maybe take
yourself for the next 30 days
where you can use that exercise in my
inbox where you put the little rubber
band around your wrist and you snap the
rubber band every time you catch
yourself talking about lack or you catch
yourself you know avoiding your finances
or you catch yourself eating the
hamburger or you catch yourself manic
manifesting just check yourself before
you wreck yourself
and sl and snap
your wrist right take that little
everybody got that
you hear yourself you're in the
conversation with your girlfriend and
you're like oh my god i can't get it i
don't know what's going on the man won't
call me back i can't kill myself oh my
god and then all of a sudden instead of
continuing
snap the rubber band
i say i forgive myself
for my lack mentality i forgive myself
for my fear i choose to see this
differently
that's it
you don't need to figure out what to see
differently you just need to say i
choose to see this differently and you
will be given all you need to see
something differently when you
before i i mean this must have been five
years ago that we did an interview in
him but before i really
understood why i was so
in control why i wasn't mean to because
i hadn't remembered my trauma and i had
you know i was living in fight or flight
i was an extreme pusher uh and in that
energy we may be able to create some
successes but we will never have that
that life that is what we truly want
fulfillment inner peace and we block
bigger stuff too we block bigger stuff
we block it because our energy is just
so frenetic
there's also the
the person who's like the manic
manifester who is very a lot of my
audience can identify with this they're
like you know reading all the books you
know reading watching lewis house
watching this you know doing this
meditation every single day
and they're just like why am i not
manifesting why am i manifesting but
it's because they've made their
spiritual practice another form of
addiction what is the thing that they
need to let go of the most if they are
doing the habits and they are doing the
steps and they are following your work
you just said it they just need to let
go
it's like you can practice these
principles but not because you think
you're going to get something you have
to practice these principles so that you
feel good and this isn't actually a book
on how to get things though it sounds
like it it's a book on how to feel good
yeah because when we feel good we're
super attracted we attract more yeah the
first step to feeling good is to decide
to stop feeling bad i've been really
working on getting honest and telling
the truth and being forthcoming about
how i'm feeling i know this is something
that can be very squirrely for people we
can get really hung up about actually
saying how you feel and telling the
truth but when we don't tell the truth
we actually stifle our energy we create
toxic relationships we carry resentments
and it builds up and builds up and
builds up so i've gotten into the
practice of this just radically telling
the truth wherever i am however i need
to be authentic and truthful about what
i'm feeling but i have a few steps that
i think are important that you need to
take in before you actually give that
truth over because if you share your
truth without cleaning up your side of
the street it'll feel like an attack
it'll feel like judgment so the process
of telling the truth is quite simple
first take a look at your side of the
street look at what's up for you if you
feel called to get honest with somebody
what is it within you that's feeling
triggered what is it that's that's
feeling activated and do whatever you
need to do to clear that whether it be
forgiving yourself for giving the other
person saying prayers for that other
person sending loving energy to that
other person and clean up the energy
before you bring over the truth because
you don't want to show up with this
nasty attitude because your truth won't
be heard you need to bring your truth
with a lot of light so that they can see
their light reflected back to them
so the process is really simple look at
your side of the street before you show
up and tell the truth and then be
prepared to get honest from a place of
love if you can tell the truth from a
place of love then you will be heard and
that's when you feel healed and that's
when a healing can be offered up to the
relationship but as long as you're
telling the truth from a place of
negativity or judgment it will not be
heard and it won't work i learned this
the hard way unfortunately but the
experience has given me this great
opportunity to learn how to tell the
truth with grace and power
the benefit of telling the truth is that
you start to feel like you're taking
care of yourself you start to feel like
you're owning your voice you're owning
your needs you're protecting yourself
when you need to protect yourself and
you're sticking up for what your values
are no matter what and you're also just
you know really getting clear about what
your boundaries may be within certain
relationships and so sometimes people
may not like your truth but you can
always trust that if you're sharing your
truth from a place of love you will be
heard even if they get defensive even if
they get upset that your loving presence
is enough to allow that truth to come
through in a very authentic way
the other part that may be very helpful
is once you've told your truth give the
person their opportunity to tell their
own hold that space for them to say how
they feel there's always two sides to
every story so speak up and then allow
the other person to speak up clearing
that space for the truth to unfold and
trusting that the truth will totally set
you free my mom has always said this to
me for my entire life the truth will set
you free the truth will set you free and
i believe that we all want freedom we
want freedom from resentment freedom
from anxiety freedom from fear and that
freedom is available as we start to open
up to the truth within us i write in the
book about how
i'm going to push the metaphysical
envelope and i'm going to go to places i
haven't gone before and i never went
there before because i didn't want to
alienate my reader and i had a lot of
new seekers that were joining me on this
journey but i feel right now that people
are completely ready for this
conversation and they can take it or
leave it yeah and make it their own yeah
and my beliefs do not have to be there
so that's a really important point that
whatever we believe when we think about
a higher power or spiritual presence is
what we believe and all that matters is
that you believe it not that someone
said it's this or that it's it's it may
be a religious spiritual belief system
it may be a belief system from your
childhood maybe something that you read
in a book that resonated with you you
decide that's the beautiful thing about
being on a spiritual path but what i
share is what i believe to be true about
what it means to connect to the voice of
our higher self our inner guidance
system and our inner wisdom versus what
it means to rely on a guide or a angel
or a deceased family member
or a loved one and so i believe we all
have these to this t we all have a team
of of guides of spiritual guides that
work on our behalf all the time and what
they're there for is often to guide be a
bridge for our thoughts so when our
thoughts are in those low vibrations if
we pray to a guide or we pray to god or
we pray to an angel we can say thank you
for for bridging my thought from this
low vibrational fear-based belief system
to a higher vibe and the way that they
would do that may be by putting a book
in front of you or guiding you to an
episode of marietv that is going to just
change your mind so guides work through
the internet and books and people and
and and your and your subconscious and
so you're gonna maybe when you have
those moments where you're like i have
this sense that i need to to watch that
episode of marietv right now maybe
somebody watching just got the hit yeah
that could have been your guide just
giving you that boost of inspiration
watch that watch that because that's
going to change you and so don't
underestimate those moments of
synchronicity because there's support
that's leading you in those
synchronistic moments and so the more
that we align with our spiritual belief
systems and the more we
allow ourselves to accept that it's good
to feel good and the more we use things
like the emotional guidance scale or the
choose again method or any of the
methods in this book the better we feel
and the better we feel the more we can
hear the guidance that we're receiving
the guidance is always there but we
block it we cut it off and so we can
open up to that guidance
i live up in the country most of the
time and i have a very good a new friend
she just had a baby she's up in the
country living in the country and she
kept her
her apartment in new york city because
she's like i'm a new yorker i just got
to keep my apartment you know she's
cutting checks every month and she's not
not there
she said
my landlord's raising my rent i don't
know what to do
and i was like okay let me ask you a few
questions
i said how does it feel
to think about writing those checks
every month
to something that you're not using
and she said oh that does not feel good
i said how does it feel to to think
about getting that baby in the car
driving down to new york city
finding a parking spot on the street of
13th street walking up the four flights
of stairs with the baby and she said oh
that sounds really overwhelming
i said well laura how does it sound to
save that money
get cozy in that house you have up in
the country and then when you want to
come to new york city just get the
fanciest apartment you could possibly
get just get like a thousand dollar a
night apartment because it doesn't
matter because you're saving that and
she was like
that sounds really fun
laura texted me yesterday that she did
not resign the lease so follow the fun
follow the fun follow the fun this is
the lesson here we're always like you
know where do i want to be what do i
want to get to but we're never asking
ourselves how do i want to feel and the
moment that we start to ask ourselves
how do i want to feel then everything
changes our point of attraction begins
to shift
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible tom bill you motivation check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there step number one
have a goal make it specific make sure
you know the rules of the game you're
playing make sure you know what a win
looks like in fact that may be the most
important question that you could ask
yourself the most pointed thing